I was out on a walk the other day with
my girlfriend pixel go in the fields
near where we live and we noticed that
lots of people had the same idea
we were all walking in these fields but
separated by a large distance and
considering that we live in the current
coronavirus pandemic this was obviously
a good thing we're very far away from
one another but it got Pixel girl
thinking and she asked me an interesting
question what is the maximum possible
social distance so how far away can
everybody be from everyone else so when
we got home naturally I did what any
good boyfriend would do I downloaded a
large geospatial data set and started
calculating just me to answer this
question you need to know two basic
things how many people are there on
earth and how much area is available to
put them in firstly the world population
is obviously increasing every day
actually increases by about 220,000
people every day on average so on any
given day you can't really hope to be
more accurate than maybe a hundred
thousand people so for the purposes of
this exercise I'm treating the world
population as seven billion eight
hundred and eleven million seven hundred
thousand people next the area available
on earth now I'm going to assume that we
don't want to put people on water or
oceans seas so we're going to be evenly
distributing people over all the
available land surface area so you could
be put in the South of France or the
Mongolian steppe or Antarctica a bit of
the luck of the draw I'm honest using
the publicly available GM Ted 2010
dataset which has an angular resolution
of 225 arcseconds we'll come back to
that number in a little bit I calculated
the available land area to be one
hundred and forty nine million six
hundred and seventy eight thousand
square kilometers so nice and simple we
take the total area divide it by the
total number of people we find that
everybody has 19 thousand 162 square
metres to roam around it if we want to
make sure that everyone is far away from
everyone else to a maximum possible
distance we set this area to be the area
of a circle
plunk ourselves in the middle then use
the formula for the area of a circle to
calculate the radius which we find to be
seventy eight point one meters however
considering that everybody else is also
going to be in their own little circle
with this same radius that means that
the maximum possible social distance
will be twice this radius or 156 point
two meters
[Music]
except that's a terrible answer it's a
terrible answer for three basic reasons
we'll go through those three corrections
and at the end of the video I'll tell
you the right answer firstly you can't
just divide the area into circles for
everyone because circles don't
tessellate that is they don't fit
together in a pattern with no gaps
between them we had to account for
what's called the packing efficiency in
other words how much of the space you
can actually use because some
mathematicians like this stuff and
because it is kind of an important
problem they've worked out with the most
efficient way to pack circles on a flat
surface is in a hexagonal pattern which
would leave only 9% of an infinite plane
covered in circles unused so the
efficiency is 91% that's easy to account
for a little bit more complicated is the
second factor at work here and that's
that there are more places we can put
people now if there are any number of
places you could put extra people but
I'm going to ignore for example the
International Space Station submarines
caves because the number of people you
could fit in these places is so small
that to be honest they're within the
error bars of what the world population
is on a given day anyway three locations
that might make a difference though are
boats planes and multi-story buildings
how many planes are there in the world
well the best guessed I could find was
from a website airliners.net which
estimated that between military planes
and commercial jets and small pleasure
craft
there's about 39,000 planes in the world
now considering that no plane has even
come close to being 100 meters long yet
that means that we can pretty safely say
that it's gonna be one person on each of
those planes so we can remove 39,000
people from the world population that
we're trying to place on the surface of
the earth
ships are much the same story in 2017
there was just shy of 58,000 registered
boats in the world but if we account for
small pleasure craft and yachts
lifeboats canoes maybe we can round it
up to a nice round 100,000 I know that's
a pretty big stretch but to be honest
when you're comparing a hundred thousand
people to several billion people this is
still gonna be a pretty small effect
multi-story buildings though are kind of
interesting so if we could put one
person on every floor of a multi-story
building we could save ourselves
tons of
space the Burj Khalifa alone for example
could house a hundred and sixty-three
people one on each floor in a tiny area
now generalizing that to all the
multi-story buildings in the world is a
really difficult calculation to try and
do
I gave it a giant ego I downloaded a
dataset from skyscraper sento comics get
the number of floors of 459 tall
buildings I then rank them on the number
of floors and plotted that nobody went
alone the less the notes they achieve up
the art lies at the top and bottom of
this looks like an exponential
distribution so taking the locker for
the number of laws and then if it's a
linear equation of the data which could
better to an explanation approximation
then it was just a simple matter if I
mean where this function be stupid with
two floors and integrating in this point
of very torus building the list give an
answer of about 70,000 you could you
could fit about 70,000 people and all
the multi-story buildings this is
actually pretty low I expected it to be
higher than this but as I said it's a
janky approximation and any
approximation of this is going to be
limited by just how spread out the data
is
so I'm happy to leave it as it is and
just except it's not the most accurate
approximation in the world but nice that
we tried to account for it plus you
could definitely argue that a single
floor separation in the building isn't
enough to maintain a proper social
distance anyway again you're comparing a
hundred thousand people ish to several
billion pretty small effect guys that
leaves just one factor to account for
but it's a big one or Agra fee orography
is how the height of land above sea
level changes as you move around
horizontally and that's important
because it actually increases the total
amount of land area available to us
imagine that there's a 150 meter cliff
and we place one person at the top of it
now if you don't account for orography
the closest you could put someone else
would be about 150 meters away
horizontally but instead of doing that
we could just put that person at the
bottom of the cliff as still 150 meters
away and so safe from the coughs and
sneezes that spread diseases more
generally if you have two people that
are some horizontal distance apart but
also some vertical distance apart then
their actual separation is going to be
given by the hypotenuse of the triangle
formed by those two distances and to
calculate that we can just use my
favorite Python library Pythagoras
speaking of Python this is why I
downloaded that GM Ted data set each
pixel here it represents a data point
showing the
height of the land in meters above sea
level to calculate the Earth's land area
before what I did was work out the area
of each pixel given by the radius of the
earth which is actually latitude
specific slightly bigger at the equator
and smaller at the poles multiplied by
the angular resolution of the data which
is that 225 arc seconds figure I
mentioned before all squared multiplied
by the cosine of latitude to account for
the fact that pixels get smaller as you
get nearer to the poles after all the
earth isn't a flat plane it's of sphere
you then add up the area of all the
pixels that are land and boom you have a
total land area but remember in
calculating the area of these pixels we
shouldn't just be looking at the
horizontal spacing of them we should be
looking at the hypotenuse formed between
them which means accounting for the
variation in height between adjacent
pixels to do this I divided up this grid
in two triangles and worked out the
hypotenuse of all of the edges given
that the height data contained in the GM
tape 2010 data set
it was then just a case of calculating
the area of all of these individual
triangles and adding up the ones which
were on land and because we've accounted
for the changes in height this area is
bigger than the area I first calculated
that simple calculation gave an area of
149 million six hundred seventy eight
thousand square kilometers accounting
for the changes in height we now find an
area of 150 million four hundred
ninety-two thousand square kilometers so
what difference does that make
well if we account for the 91% hexagonal
packing efficiency for over two hundred
thousand people on planes boats and
multi-story buildings and more
importantly account for changes in
orography we find that the maximum
possible social distance is one hundred
and forty nine point four meters so all
of those factors combined produced a
loss of some seven meters of maximum
possible social distance now all of the
loss in that was because of the packing
efficiency but accounting for the
orography for the changes in the height
of the earth actually clawed it back
about forty centimeters of maximum
possible social distance for everyone on
earth incidentally all the space we
gained from putting people in planes and
boats in a multi-story buildings
about two millimeters per person and I
actually checked if we were under
estimating the number of people we could
put in buildings by a factor of 10 then
we would have gained some six
millimeters extra it's still a really
small contribution guys I just knew that
if I didn't talk about it the comments
would be full of it
of course there are lots of small
factors to still consider and I do
expect to see them talked about down
there in the comments such as you know
subgrid processes like not fitting
people into rivers or into lakes so how
you pack people on tiny islands or
pinches efficiently but these are
sub-grid processes meaning that they
occur a scale smaller than the
resolution of the data that I have if
you happen to have incredibly high
resolution spatial data and you want to
tackle this and do this video again with
high resolution please be my guest but
still I hope that this video showed you
that what at first glance seems to be
quite a simple calculation actually has
some quite interesting and quite
important caveats and also that even in
a worst case scenario we have to spread
out as much as possible we actually have
quite a bit of space to go around
according to my calculations the amount
of space that we would each have in this
scenario would mean we could each own
our own mark square invents it just
might be in Antarctica I hope that you
are all staying safe and at home
wherever you are and if you're not if
you're one of these people doing a key
profession like working in hospital or
stocking groceries or keeping the lights
on then thank you so much for what you
are doing let's hope that we can all go
back to normal as soon as the
circumstances allow if you did enjoy the
video then please do share it in your
coronavirus group chats because
everybody has several and pop it a like
and if you are still after stuff to
occupy yourself with to watch then I've
made lots of videos here's to just up
there but just leaves me to say thank
you very much for watching and I'll see
you in the next one now wash your hands